The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so.
This is a big day.
Part One of the
course is completed,
and I have your quizzes
for you, and that
was a very successful
result, I'm very pleased.
I hope you are, too.
Quiz average of 85, that's on
the first part of the course.
And then the second part --
so this is Chapter 3 now --
Starts in one dimension with
an equation of a type that
we've already seen a little bit.
So there's some
more things to say
about the equation
and the framework,
but then we get to make a start
on the finite element approach
to solving it.
We could of course-- In 1-D
finite differences are probably
the way to go, actually.
In one dimension the special
success of finite elements
doesn't really show up that much
because finite elements have
been, I mean one great
reason for their success
is that they handle
different geometries.
They're flexible; you
could have regions
in the plane, three-dimensional
bodies of different shapes.
Finite differences
doesn't really
know what to do on a
curved boundary in in 2-
or 3-D. Finite elements
copes much better.
So, we'll make a start
today, more Friday
on one-dimensional
finite elements
and then, a couple
of weeks later
will be the real
thing, 2-D and 3-D.
OK, so, ready to
go on Chapter 3?
So, that's our equation
and everybody sees
right away what's the
framework, that that's
A transpose; in some way
this is A transpose C A,
but what's new of course is that
we're dealing with functions,
not vectors.
So we're dealing with, you could
say, operators, not matrices.
And nevertheless, the big
picture is still as it was.
So let me take u(x) to be
the displacements again.
So I'm thinking more of
mechanics than electronics
here.
Displacements, and
then we have du--
the e(x) will be
du/dx, that'll be
the stretching, the elongation
and, of course at that step
you already see the
big new item, the fact
that the A, the one that
gets us from u to du/dx,
instead of being a difference
matrix which it has been,
our matrix A is
now a derivative.
A is d/dx.
So maybe I'll just
take out that arrow.
So A is d/dx.
OK, but if we dealt OK
with difference matrices,
we're going to deal
OK with derivatives.
Then, of course, this is the
C part, that produces w(x).
And it's a multiplication
by this possibly varying,
possibly jumping
stiffness constant c(x).
So w(x) is c(x) e(x), that's our
old w=Ce, this is Hooke's Law.
I'll put Hooke's
Law, but that's,
or whose-ever law it is.
It's like a diagonal
matrix; I hope
you see that it's like
a diagonal matrix.
This function u is kind
of like of a vector
but a continuum vector
instead of just a fixed,
finite number of values.
Then at each value we
used to multiply by c_i,
now our values are continuous
with x, so we multiply by c(x).
And then you're going to
expect that, going up here,
there's going to be an A
transpose w f, and of course
that A transpose
we have to identify
and that's the first point
of the lecture, really.
To identify what is A transpose.
What do I mean by A transpose?
And I've got to say
right away that I'm
a little, the notation, writing
a transpose of a derivative is
like, that's not legal.
Because we think of the
transpose of a matrix,
you sort of flip it
over the main diagonal,
but obviously it's got to be
something more to it than that.
And so that's a
central math part
of this lecture is what's really
going on when you transpose?
Because then we can
copy what's going on
and it's quite
important to get it.
Because the transpose,
well, other notations
and other words for it
would be-- A notation
might be a star.
Star would be way more
common than transpose,
I'll just stay with
transpose because I
want to keep pressing the
parallel with A transpose C A.
And the name for it
would be the adjoint.
And adjoint methods, and adjoint
operator, those appear a lot.
And you'll see them
appear in finite elements.
So this is a good
thing to catch on to.
Why?
Why should the transpose or
the adjoint of the derivative
be minus the derivative?
And by the way, just
while we're fixing this,
this is a key fact then,
which is certainly--
We have a very strong hint from
centered difference, right?
If I think of derivatives,
if I associate them
with differences, the
centered difference matrix,
so the A matrix may be centered,
would be-- Just to remind us,
a centered difference has
ones and minus one, one,
zeroes on the diagonal, right?
Minus one, one.
Takes that difference
at every row.
Except possibly boundary rows.
And of course as soon as you
look at that matrix you see,
yeah, it's anti-symmetric.
That's an anti-symmetric matrix.
So A transpose is minus A
for centered differences
and therefore we're
not so surprised
to see a minus sign
up here when we
go to the continuous
case, the derivative.
But, we still have
to say what it means.
So that's what I'll do next, OK?
So this is a good thing to know.
And I was just going
to comment, what
would be the transpose
of the second derivative?
I won't even write this down.
If the derivative transpose
sort of flips its sign to minus,
what would you guess
for this transpose
of second derivative, our
more familiar d second
by dx squared?
Well we'll have two minus signs.
So it'll come out plus.
So second derivatives,
even order derivatives
are sort of like symmetric guys.
Odd order derivatives, first
and third and fifth derivatives,
well, God forbid we ever
meet a fifth derivative,
but first derivative
anyway, is anti-symmetric.
Except for boundary conditions.
So I really have to
emphasize that the boundary
conditions come in.
And you'll see them come in.
They have to come in.
OK, so what meaning can I
assign to the transpose,
or what was the real thing
happening when we flipped
the matrix across its diagonal?
I claim that we really define
the transpose by this rule,
by-- We know what
inner products are.
I'll do vectors first, we
know about inner products,
dot products, we know what the
dot product of two vectors is.
So, this is the
transpose of A. How
am I going to define
the transpose of A?
Well, I look at the dot
product of Au with w.
I'll use a dot here for once,
I may erase it and replace it.
If at the dot product of Au
with w, then that equals,
for all u and w,
all vectors u and w,
that equals the dot product
of u with something.
Because u is coming-- If I write
out what the dot product is,
I see u_1 multiplies something,
u_2 multiplies something.
And what goes in
that little space?
This is just an identity.
I mean, it's like,
you'll say no big deal.
But I'm saying there is at
least a small deal here.
OK.
So if I write it
this way, you'll
tell me right away this should
be the same as u transpose
times something.
And again, so I'm asking for the
same something on both lines.
What is that something?
A transpose w.
Whatever A transpose
is, it's the matrix
that makes this right.
That's really my message.
That A transpose
is-- The reason we
flipped the matrix
across the diagonal
is that it makes that
equation correct.
And I'm writing the
same thing here.
OK.
So again, if we knew
what dot products were,
what inner product
of vectors were,
then A transpose
is the matrix that
makes this identity correct.
And of course if
you write it all out
in terms of i, j,
every component,
you find it is correct.
So that defines the
transpose of a matrix.
And of course it coincides with
flipping across the diagonal.
Now, how about the
transpose of a derivative.
OK, so I'm going to
follow the same rule.
Here A is now going
to be the derivative,
and A transpose is
going to be whatever
it takes to make this true.
But what do I mean?
Now I have functions, so
I have to think again,
what do I mean by the inner
product, the dot product?
So for this to make
sense I need to say,
and it's a very
important thing anyway,
and it's the right
natural choice,
I need to say the dot
product, or the inner product
is a better word, of functions.
Of two functions.
Say e(x) and w(x).
If I have two functions, what do
I mean by their inner product?
Well, really I just
think back what
did we mean in the
finite dimensional case,
I multiplied each e by a w,
each component of e by w,
and I added, so what
am I going to do here?
Maybe my notation
should be parentheses
with a comma would be better
than a dot, for functions.
So I have a function.
I'm in function space now.
We moved out of R^n today,
into function space.
Our vectors have
become functions.
And now what's the dot
product of two vectors?
Well, what am I going to do?
I'm going to do
what I have to do.
I'm going to multiply each
e by its corresponding w,
and now they depend on
this continuous variable x,
so that's e(x) times w(x).
And what do I do now?
Integrate.
Here I added e_i
times w_i, of course.
Over here I have functions.
I integrate dx.
Over whatever the region
of the problem is.
And then our example's in
1-D, it'll zero to one.
If these are functions
of two variables
I'd be integrating over some 2-D
region, but we're in 1-D today.
OK, so you see that I'm prepared
to say-- This now makes sense.
I now want to say, I'm going
to let A be the derivative,
and I'm going to figure out
what A transpose has to be.
So if A is the derivative,
so now is this key step.
Why is the transpose that?
OK, so I look at the
derivative, du/dx, with w,
so that's this integral, from
zero to one of du/dx*w(x)dx,
so that's my left side.
Now I want to get u by itself.
I want to get the
dot product, so I
want to get another integral
here that has u(x) by itself.
Times something,
and that something
is what I'm looking for.
That something will
be A transpose w.
Right?
Do you see what I'm doing?
This is is the dot
product, this is Auw,
so I've written out what
Au inner product with w is.
And now I want to get u out by
itself and what it multiplies
here will be the A
transpose w, and my rule
will be extended to the function
case and I'll be ready to go.
Now do you recognize, this
is a basic calculus step,
what rule of calculus
am I going to use?
We're back to 18.01.
I have the integral of
a derivative times w,
and what do I want to do?
I want to get the
derivative off of u.
What happens?
What's it called?
Integration by parts.
Very important thing.
Very important.
You miss its
importance in calculus.
It gets sometimes introduced
as a rule, or a trick
to find some goofy integral,
but it's really the real thing.
So what is integration by parts?
What's the rule?
You take the
derivative off of u,
you put it onto the other
one just what we hope for,
and then you also
have to remember
that there is a minus sign.
Integration by parts
has a minus sign.
And usually you'd
see it out there
but here I've left
more room for it there.
So I have identified
now A transpose w.
A transpose w has-- If this
is Au, inner product with w,
then this is u inner
product with A transpose w,
it had to be what was.
And so that one integration by
parts brought out a minus sign.
If I was looking at
second derivatives
there would probably be
somewhere two integration
by parts; I'd have minus
twice, I'd be back to plus.
And you're going to ask
about boundary conditions.
And you're right to ask
I even circled that, because
that is so important.
So what we've done so far
is to get the interior
of the interval right.
Between zero and one,
if A is the derivative,
then A transpose is
minus the derivative.
That's all we've done.
We have not got the
boundary conditions yet.
And we can't go on without that.
OK, so I'm ready
now to say something
about boundary conditions.
And it will bring up this
square versus rectangular also.
We're getting the rules
straight before we
tackle finite elements.
OK, let me take an example of
a matrix and its transpose.
Just so you see how boundary
conditions-- Suppose
I have a free-fixed problem.
Suppose I have a
free-fixed line of springs.
What's the matrix A for that?
Well-- Question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
That's-- Yes, when I learned it,
it was also that stupid trick.
So you would like me to put
plus, can I put plus, whatever.
What do you want
me to call that?
An integrated term?
It would be, yeah.
I even remember what it is.
As you do better than me. u
times w at the, is that good?
Yeah, I think.
So it's really this part
that I'm now coming to.
It's the boundary part
And let me say, so I'm glad
you asked that question
because I made it
seem unimportant,
where that's not true at all.
The boundary condition is
part of the definition of A,
and part of the
definition of A transpose.
Just the way, I'm about
to say free-fixed,
I had to tell you that for
you to know what A was.
Until I tell you the
boundary condition,
you don't know what
the boundary rows are.
You only know the
inside of the matrix.
Or one possible inside.
So I'm thinking
my inside is going
to be minus one,
one; minus one, one;
so on, as giving me
finite differences.
Minus one, one.
But.
Oh no, let's see.
So I'm doing free-fixed.
Is that right?
Am I doing free-fixed?
OK, so am I taking
free at the left end?
Yes.
Alright, so if I'm
free at the left
and fixed at the right
end, what's my A?
We're getting better
at this, right?
Minus one, one.
Minus one, and the one
here gets chopped off.
You could say if you want
the fifth row of A_0,
remembering A_0 as the
hint on the quiz, where
it had five rows for the
full thing, free-free.
And then when an end got fixed,
the fifth column got removed,
and that's my free-fixed matrix.
At the left hand
end, at the zero end,
it's got the
difference in there.
Difference,
difference, difference.
But here at the
right-hand end, it's
the fixing, the setting
u, whatever it would be,
u_5 to zero, or maybe it's u_4.
if this is u nought, one, two,
three.
Setting u_4 to zero
knocked that out.
OK.
All I want to do
is transpose that.
And you'll see something that
we maybe didn't notice before.
So I transpose it,
that's minus one,
one becomes a column, minus
one, one becomes a column.
Minus one, one becomes a column.
Minus one, all there is.
That row becomes, so this
was, so-- Have I got it right?
Yes.
What's happened?
A transpose, what are
the boundary conditions
going with A transpose?
The boundary conditions
that went with A
were, let me say
first, what were
the boundary conditions with A?
Those are going to be
boundary conditions on u.
So A has boundary
conditions on u.
And A transpose has
boundary conditions on w.
Because A transpose acts
on w, and A acts on u.
So there was no choice.
So now what was the
boundary condition here?
The boundary condition
was u_4=0, right?
That was what I meant by
that guy getting fixed.
Now-- And no boundary
condition at u_0, it was free.
Now, what are the
boundary conditions
that go with A transpose?
And remember, A transpose
is multiplying w.
I'm going to put w here, so
what are the boundary conditions
that go with A transpose?
This thing, nothing
got knocked off.
The boundary condition came
up here for A transpose,
the boundary
condition was w_0=0.
That got knocked
out, w_0 to be zero.
No surprise.
Free-fixed, this is the
free end at the left,
this is the fixed
end at the right.
Did you ever notice that
the matrix does it for you?
I mean, when you transpose that
matrix it just automatically
built in the correct
boundary conditions on w by,
you started with the conditions
on u, you transpose the matrix
and you've discovered what the
boundary conditions on w are.
And I'm going to do the same
for the continuous problem.
I'm going to do the same for
the continuous problem, so
the continuous free-fixed.
OK, what's the boundary
condition on u?
If it's free-fixed, I just
want you to repeat this,
on the interval zero
to one for functions
u(x), w(x) instead
of for vectors.
What's the boundary
condition on u,
if I have a free-fixed
problem? u(1)=0.
u of one equals zero.
So this is the
boundary conditions
that goes with A in
the free-fixed case.
And this is part
of A. That is part
of A. I don't know what A
is until I know its boundary
condition.
Just the way I don't
know what this matrix is.
It could have been
A_0, it could have
lost one column, it could have
lost two columns, whatever.
I don't know until I've told
you the boundary condition on u.
And then transposing is going
to tell me, automatically,
without any further input,
the boundary condition that
goes on the adjoint.
So what's the boundary
condition on w that
goes as part of A transpose?
Well, you're going to tell me.
Tell me. w(0) should be zero.
It came out
automatically, naturally.
This is a big distinction
between boundary conditions.
I would call that an
essential boundary condition.
I had to start with it,
I had to decide on that.
And then this, I call a
natural boundary condition.
Or there are even
two guys' names,
which are associated
with these two types.
So maybe a first chance to
just mention these names.
Because you'll often
see, reading some paper,
maybe a little on the
mathematical side,
you'll see that word used.
The guy's name with this
sort of boundary condition
is a French name.
Not so easy to say, Dirichlet.
I'll say it more
often in the future.
Anyway, I would call that a
Dirichlet condition and you
would say it's a fixed
boundary condition.
And if you were
doing heat flow you
would say it's a
fixed temperature.
Whatever.
Fixed, is really the
word to remember there.
OK, and then I guess I better
give Germany a shot here, too.
So the natural
boundary condition
is associated with
the name of Neumann.
So if I said a Dirichlet
problem, a total Dirichlet
problem, I would be
speaking about fixed-fixed.
And if I spoke about
a Neumann problem
I would be talking
about free-free.
And this problem is Dirichlet at
one end, Neumann at the other.
Anyway, so essential
and natural.
And now of course I'm
hoping that that's
going to make this
boundary term go away.
OK, now I'm paying
attention to this thing
that you made me write. uw.
OK, what happens there?
uw?
Oh, right this
isn't bad because it
shows that there's a--
Boundary condition,
I've got some little
deals going with them
But do you see that
that becomes zero?
Why is it zero at
the top end, at one?
When I take u times w at
one, why do I get zero?
Because u(1) is zero.
Good.
And at the bottom end.
When I take uw at the other
boundary, why do I get zero?
Because of w.
You see that w was needed.
That w(0) was needed because
there was no controlling u(0).
I had no control of u
at the left-hand end,
because it was free.
So the control has
to come from w.
And so w naturally
had to be zero,
because I wasn't controlling
u at that left-hand, free end.
So one way or the other,
the integration by parts
is the key.
So that's said what
I critically wanted
to say about transposing,
taking the adjoint,
except I was just going to add
a comment about this square A
versus rectangular.
And this was a case
of square, right?
This was a case,
this free-fixed case,
this example I happened
to pick was square.
A_0, the free-free guy that
was a hint on the quiz,
was rectangular.
The fixed-fixed, which
was also on the quiz,
was also rectangular.
It was what, four by
three or something.
This A is four by four.
And what is especially
nice when it's square?
If our problem happens
to give a square matrix,
in the truss case if the
number of displacement unknowns
happens to equal the number
of bars, so m equals n,
I have a square matrix A. And
this guy's invertible, so it's
all good.
Oh, that's maybe
the whole point.
That if it's
rectangular I wouldn't
talk about its inverse.
But this is a square matrix,
so A itself has an inverse.
Instead of having,
as I usually have,
to deal with A transpose
C A all at once,
let me put this comment because
it's just a small one up here.
Right under these words.
Square versus rectangular.
Square A, and let's
say invertible,
otherwise we're in
the unstable case,
so you know what I
mean, in the network
problems the number of nodes
matches the number of edges?
In the spring problem we
have free-fixed situations.
Anyway, A comes out square.
Whatever the application.
If it comes out square,
what is especially good?
It comes out square,
what's especially
good is that it has an inverse.
So that in this square case,
this K inverse is A transpose C
A inverse, can be split.
This allows us to
separate, to do what
you better not do otherwise.
In other words, we--
Our three steps,
which usually mash together
and we can't separate them
and we have to deal with
the whole matrix at once.
In this square case,
they do separate.
And so that's worth noticing.
It means that we
can solve backwards,
we can solve these
three one at a time.
The inverses can
be done separately.
When A and A
transpose are square,
then from this
equation I can find w.
From knowing w I
can find e, just
by inverting C. By
knowing e I can find u,
just by inverting A.
You see the three steps?
You could invert that, and then
you can invert the middle step,
and you can invert
A. And you've got u.
So the square case
is worth noticing.
It's special enough
that in this case
we would have an easy problem.
And this case is called,
for trusses and mechanics,
there's a name for this.
And unfortunately
it's a little long.
Statically, that's
not the key word,
determinate is the key word.
Statically determinate,
that goes with square.
And you can guess what
the rectangular matrix A,
what word would I use, what's
the opposite of determinate?
It's got to be indeterminate.
Rectangular A will
be indeterminate.
And all that is
referring to is the fact
that in the determinate case the
forces determine the stresses.
You don't have to take
that, get all three
together, mix them,
invert, go backwards.
All that.
You just can do them one at the
time in this determinate case.
And now I guess I'd better
say, so here's the matrix case.
But now in this chapter I always
have to do the continuous part.
So let me just stay
with free-fixed,
what is this balance equation?
So this is my force balance.
I didn't give it its moment
but its moment has come now.
So the force balance
equation is -dw/dx,
because A transpose is minus
a derivative, equal f(x).
And my free boundary
condition, my free end,
gave me w of what was it?
The Neumann guy gave me w(0)=0.
And what's the point?
Do you see what I'm saying?
I'm saying that this free-fixed
is a beautiful example
of determinate.
Square matrix A
in the matrix case
and the parallel in
the continuous case
is-- I can solve that for w(x).
I can solve directly for w(x).
Without involving, you see
I didn't have to know c(x).
I hadn't even got that far.
I'm just going backwards now.
I can solve this, just the
way I can invert that matrix.
Inverting the matrix here is the
same as solving the equation.
You see I have a first
order, first derivative?
I mean, it's a trivial
equation, right?
It's the equation you solved in
the final problem of the quiz,
where an f was a delta function.
It was simple because it was
a square, determinate problem
with one condition on w.
When both conditions are on u,
then it's not square any more.
OK for that point?
Determinate versus
indeterminate.
OK.
So that's sort of, and
I could do examples.
Maybe I've asked
you on the homework
to take a particular f(x).
I hope it was a
free-fixed problem,
if I was feeling good that
day, because free-fixed you'll
be able to get w(x) right away.
If it was fixed-fixed
then I apologize,
it's going to take you a
little bit longer to get to w.
To get to u.
OK.
But this, of course,
I just integrate.
Inverting a difference matrix
is just integrating a function.
Good.
OK, so this lecture so
far was the transition
from vectors and
matrices to functions
and continuous problems.
And then, of course
we're going to get deep
into that because we got partial
differential equations ahead.
But today let's stay
in one dimension
and introduce finite elements.
OK.
Ready for finite elements,
so that's now a major step.
Finite differences, maybe
I'll mention this, probably
in this afternoon's review
session, where I'll just
be open to homework problems.
I'll say something more
about truss examples,
and I might say something about
finite differences for this.
But really, it's finite elements
that get introduced right now.
So let me do that.
Finite elements and
introducing them.
OK.
So the prep, the getting
ready for finite elements
is to get hold of
something called
the weak form of the equation.
So that's going to be a
statement of the-- Finite
elements aren't appearing yet.
Matrices are not appearing yet.
I'm talking about the
differential equation.
But what do I mean
by this weak form?
OK, let me just go
for it directly.
You see the equation up there?
Let me copy it.
So here's the strong form.
The strong form is, you would
say, the ordinary equation.
Strong form is what
our equation is, minus
d/dx of c(x) du/dx equal f(x).
OK, that's the strong form.
That's the equation.
Now, how do I get
to the weak form?
Let me just go to it directly
and then over the next days
we'll see why it's so
natural and important.
If I go for it directly,
what I do is this.
I multiply both sides of
the equation by something
I'll call a test function.
And I'll try to
systematically use
the letter v for the
test function. u will
be the solution. v
isn't the solution,
v is like any function that I
test this equation in this way.
I'm just multiplying both sides
by the same thing, some v(x).
Any v(x).
We'll see if there are
any limitations, OK?
And I integrate.
OK.
So you're going to
say nope, no problem.
I integrate from zero to one.
Alright, this would
be true for f.
So now I'll erase
the word strong form,
because the strong form
isn't on the board anymore.
It's the weak form now
that we're looking at.
And this is for any, and
I'll put "any" in quotes
just because eventually I'll
say a little more about this.
I'll write the
equation this way.
And you might think, OK, if
this has to hold for every v(x),
I could let v(x) be
concentrated in a little area.
And this would
have to hold, then
I could try another
v(x), concentrated
around other points.
You can maybe feel that if
this holds for every v(x),
then I can get back
to the strong form.
If this holds for every
v(x), then somehow
that had better be
the same as that.
Because if this was
f(x)+1 and this is f(x),
then I wouldn't have
the equality any more.
Should I just say that again?
It's just like, at this
point it's just a feeling,
that if this is
true for every v(x),
then that part had
better equal that part.
That'll be my way back
to the strong form.
It's a little bit
like climbing a hill.
Going downhill was easy, I just
multiplied by v and integrated.
Nobody objected to that.
I'm saying I'll be
able to get back
to the strong form
with a little patience.
But I like the weak form.
That's the whole point.
You've got to begin
to like the weak form.
If you begin to take
it in and think OK.
Now, why do I like it?
What am I going to
do to that left side?
The right side's cool, right?
It looks good.
Left side does not
look good to me.
When you see something like
that, what do you think?
Today's lecture has
already said what to think.
What should I do to
make that look better?
I should, yep.
Integrate by parts.
If I integrate by
parts, you see what
I don't like about it as it is,
is two derivatives are hitting
u, and v is by itself.
And I want it to be symmetric.
I'm going to integrate
this by parts,
this is minus the
derivative of something.
Times v. And when I integrate
by parts, I'm going to have,
it'll be an integral.
And can you integrate
by parts now?
I mean, you probably haven't
thought about integration
by parts for a while.
Just think of it as taking
the derivative off of this,
so it leaves that by itself.
And putting it onto v, so
it's dv/dx, and remembering
the minus sign, but
we have a minus sign
so now it's coming up plus.
That's the weak form.
Can I put a circle
around the weak form?
Well, that wasn't
exactly a circle.
OK.
But that's the weak form.
For every v, this
is-- I could give you
a physical interpretation but
I won't do it just this minute.
This is going to hold for
any v. That's the weak form.
OK.
Good.
Now, why did I want to do that?
The person who reminds me
about boundary conditions
should remind me again.
That when I did this
integration by parts,
there should have been also--
What's the integrated part now,
that has to be evaluated
at zero and one?
This c, so it's that
times that, right?
It's that c(x) du/dx times v(x).
Maybe minus.
Yeah, you're right.
Minus.
Good.
What do I want this to come out?
Zero, of course.
I don't want to think
about this anymore.
Alright, so now I'm doing
this free-fixed problem still.
So what's the deal about
the free-fixed f problem?
Well, let's see.
OK, I got the two ends and
I want them to be zero.
OK, now at the free
end, I'm not controlling
v. I wasn't controlling
u and I'm not
going to be controlling
its friend v.
So this had to be zero.
So this part will be
zero at the free end.
That boundary condition has
just appeared again naturally.
I had to have it because
I had no control over v.
And what about at the fixed end.
At the fixed end,
which-- Is that?
At the free end.
Now, what's up at the fixed end?
What was the fixed end?
That's where u was zero.
I'm going to make v also zero.
So there's, when
I said any v(x),
I better put in with v=0
at the Dirichlet point,
at fixed point, at fixed end.
I need that.
I need to know that v
is zero at that end.
I had u=0.
Here's why I'm fine.
So I'm saying that any time
I have a Dirichlet condition,
a fixed condition that
tells me u, I think of v
and you'll begin to think of
v as a little movement away
from u. u is the solution.
Now, remind me,
this was free-fixed.
So the u might have been
something like this.
I just draw that.
That's my u.
This guy was fixed, right?
By u.
Now, I'm thinking of
v's as, the letter
v is very fortunate
because it stands
for virtual displacement.
A virtual displacement is
a little displacement away
from u, but it has to satisfy
the zero-- the fixed condition
that u satisfied.
In other words, the
little virtual v
can't move away from zero.
So I get this term is
zero at the fixed end.
OK.
That's the little
five minute time-out
to check the boundary
condition part.
The net result is
that that term's gone
and I've got the weak
form as I wanted.
OK, three minutes to
start to tell you how to
use the weak form.
So this is called
Galerkin's method.
And it starts with
the weak form.
So he's Russian.
Russia gets into
the picture now.
We had France and Germany
with the boundary conditions,
now we've got Russia with
this fundamental principle
of how to turn a
continuous problem
into a discrete problem.
That's what
Galerkin's idea does.
Instead of a function unknown
I want to have n unknowns.
I want to get a discrete
equation which will eventually
be KU=F. So I'm going to
get to an equation KU=F,
but not by finite
difference, right?
I could, but I'm not.
I'm doing it this weak,
Galerkin, finite element way.
OK, so if I tell you the
Galerkin idea then next time we
bring in, we have libraries
of finite elements.
But you have to get
the principle straight.
So it's Galerkin's idea.
Galerkin's idea was was
choose trial functions.
Let me call them call them u_1?
No, I won't call them--
Have to get the names right.
Phi.
OK, the Greeks get a shot.
OK.
Trial functions,
phi_1(x) up to phi_n(x).
OK, so that's a choice you make.
And we have a free choice.
And it's a fundamental choice
for all of applied math here.
You choose some functions,
and if you choose them well
you get a great method,
if you choose them badly
you got a lousy method.
OK, so you choose
trial functions,
and now what's the
idea going to be?
Your approximate U,
approximate solution
will be some
combination of this.
So combinations of those, let
me call the coefficients U's,
because those are the unknowns.
Plus U_n*phi_n.
So those are the unknowns.
The n unknowns.
I'll even remove
that for the moment.
You see, these are
functions of x.
And these are numbers.
So our unknown, our
n unknown numbers
are the coefficients to be
decided of the functions
we chose.
OK, now I need n equations.
I've got n unknowns now,
they're the unknown coefficients
of these functions.
I need an equation so I get
n equations by choose test
functions, V_1, V_2, up to V_n.
Each V will give me an equation.
So I'll have n equations at
the end, I have n unknowns,
I'll have a square matrix.
And that'll be a linear system.
I'll get to KU=F.
But do you see how
I'm getting there?
I'm getting there by
using the weak form,
by using Galerkin's idea
of picking some trial
functions, and some
test functions,
and putting them
into the weak form.
So Galerkin's idea is,
take these functions
and these functions.
And apply the weak form
just to those guys.
Not to, the real weak form,
the continuous weak form,
was for a whole lot of
V. We'll get n equations
by picking n V's, and we'll get
n unknowns by picking n phis.
So this method, this idea,
was a hundred years older
than finite elements.
The finite element idea
was a particular choice
of these guys, a particular
choice of the phis
and the V's as
simple polynomials.
And you might think
well, why didn't Galerkin
try those first, maybe he did.
But the key is that now,
with the computing power
we now have compared
to Galerkin,
we can choose
thousands of functions.
If we keep them simple.
So that's really what the
finite element brought,
finite element brought
is, keep the functions
as simple polynomials
and take many of them.
Where Galerkin, who
didn't have MATLAB,
he probably didn't even
have a desk computer,
he used pencil and paper,
he took one function.
Or maybe two.
I mean, that took him a day.
But we take thousands of
functions, simple functions,
and we'll see on Friday the
steps that get us to KU=F.
So this is the prep
for finite elements.